[Music]
right hurricane Florence will soon make
landfall on the southeastern coast of
the United States we'll go to our
reporters in just a minute thousands of
US National Guard members they're
standing by FEMA is on full alert
we have stockpiles of emergency
resources we have food water supplies
cots blankets baby formula where it's
all been pre-positioned to help the
people that are victims of this storm
Virginia North South Carolina Georgia
all currently operating under a state of
emergency mandatory evacuations have now
been in place for days now this is a
serious looming national disaster sadly
we have people in this country on the
left while they're trying to make the
storm a political issue if you can
believe that some literally blaming
President Trump for the extreme weather
like he had control over a hurricane if
the editorial board over the Washington
Post literally claiming the Trump is
complicit in causing the hurricane you
can't make this up because of his quote
efforts to dismantle environmental
protections that caused the hurricane so
we get this straight the left won't give
President Trump credit for the booming
economy or moving towards energy
independence or the progress with North
Korea and no missiles being fired over
Japan or the victory over Isis or tax
cuts are so much more but somehow they
want you to believe he's responsible for
mother nature and by the way in less
than two years of office he's become
that Almighty and powerful that he can
collude with God in this case and create
massive hurricanes
it's beyond sick and beyond ugly and
twisted this derangement syndrome state
of psychosis is now reaching heights of
what is borderline insanity is not just
the abusively bias Washington Post
either trying to politicize this
hurricane Florence take a look
President Trump says FEMA is ready for
hurricane Florence but mounting evidence
suggests it could be incredibly
difficult to deal with this disaster if
climate change deniers are on the front
lines of emergency response but when ten
million dollars is taken out of the FEMA
budget and reallocated to ice for
detention facilities right before the
hurricane season those questions are
being asked right now in the
appropriations committees
elevating Trump to evil whereas having
raised three kids I just think he's a
giant toddler with no real connection to
reality and no sense of empathy or
responsibility he came across as almost
gleeful and excited about the hurricane
and how big it was and how tremendously
wet it's going to be and all these
absurd things that came out of his mouth
according to two Harvard scientists
Trump's environmental policies could
lead to an additional 80,000 unnecessary
deaths every decade he is so consumed by
the calamity that exists and the cats
that exist that he's not really prepared
and focused because he spends every
weekend golfing instead of preparing are
these people have lost their mind well
more on that in just a minute but first
we go live to Leland Vitter he is
standing by in North Carolina in the
middle of all of this and the winds have
kicked up considerably in just the last
few minutes Leland thank you what's
going on there it looks like you have to
hold on to stand up you really do Shawn
and now we almost just got blown over
here it gives you a sense though of the
power of this storm that keeps
increasing in that the people here who
are either watching their homes and
their communities on television or those
who have decided to ride this one out
have got a long long way to go slow
Florence is effectively slowed down now
and just creeping along more dearly when
you're in an area like this that is that
the worst of the worst if you will it
only lasts a couple of hours this is
going to be about 24 hours of
hurricane-force winds that we're just
now really feeling the real effects of
the rising tide now is coming in which
is a terrible combination with a storm
surge that will certainly destroy this
dock and then send these dock sections
into town to destroy anything and
everything in its path and you watch
this rain come down it is at some point
is going to be 40 inches of rain which
equals feet of flooding so those who did
not evacuate certainly have no chance to
do so right now police and fire tell us
that they just are not able to respond
in these kinds of conditions even for
people in life-threatening situations in
time so folks are pretty much out and on
their own until the storm passes and
then the water starts to rise all over
North Carolina but certainly along the
beach front and the waterfront power has
been out for hours now and could be out
for weeks to come as this water
continues to come in high tide continues
to come in and these hurricane-force
winds will only get stronger Sean all
right Leland better be careful this is
where reporters really put their lives
on the line bring us the story live
where it takes place it's extremely
dangerous be careful please here also
joining us now Steve Harrigan
he's also North Carolina tonight as the
storm now begins to kick in Steve what's
happening from your vantage point Sean
we've seen things get worse each hour
pretty much steadily right now I'm
starting to hear things break in the
darkness the electricity is out here
it's out for more than a hundred
thousand people at least along the coast
of North Carolina that could go up to
three million by the end of this but it
looks like some some of the construction
on the building opposite me is starting
to blow off we've seen these winds reach
tropical storm-force over the next
couple hours we expect them to reach
hurricane force so things are going to
get worse overnight
now first responders are ready the Army
is here the National Guard is here swift
boat rescue teams from 19 states that
come here to volunteer to try help
people most of the people have listened
they've gotten out they've board up
their houses put a few here it could be
a rough couple of days they close down
the bridge that goes from this island to
the mainland there's no power it's just
getting worse and worse as these sheets
of rain continue to come down Sean back
to you all right Steve Harrigan also you
to be safe we'll be checking in with
Steve and Leland Vitter all throughout
the show also coming up whether bail
calms Joe Bastardi he's going to weigh
in on some of the ridiculous claims that
we just showed you Plus well a full
hurricane coverage from the ground all
throughout the show tonight first we do
have breaking right now we do have new
information surrounding the deep state
tonight that we want to share with you
we'll keep up pictures of the storm as
it continues to go on but we are now on
day four of more damning revelations new
developments surrounding Lisa Paige and
Peter struck tonight we have two new
stories to bring you the first
foxnews.com we have new texts that are
showing that Lisa Paige may have once
actually interned under former President
Clinton on January 19 2017 she texted
her then-boyfriend Peter struck quote
needless to say it was very different
when I intern there under Clinton and of
course after all the previously
unearthed anti-trump role in text
messages should we really be surprised
this is just the cherry on top of a long
record of what we now know is political
bias at the highest levels of the FBI
the DOJ also we see Director of National
Intelligence and the CIA as we told you
last night
our second news story tonight
surrounding Paige and struck may reveal
potential serious wrongdoings again
within the top ranks of the FBI tonight
Judicial Watch just received dozens of
previously unseen documents from the DOJ
including email exchanges between the
general counsel remember he left a while
back James Baker deputy director Andrew
McCabe a grand jury has now been
convened looking into him struck Paige
and others now this newly found email
chain Memphis referenced a sensitive
data exchange program with European
Intel agencies it was sent over an
unsecured device email account page even
references writing in all caps and bleep
given everything going on why is
redacted using a yahoo account for this
actually apparently a yahoo account from
redacted I pad make him stop
now given all these developments all
throughout the week this is four nights
in a row surrounding the rampant
political leaking and bias and abuse of
power
miss handling a sensitive information we
should all demand a lot more finally
from the highest ranking government
officials those responsible for this
deep state bureaucratic corruption need
to be held accountable in a court of law
we also know this goes right in a Robert
Muller's office visa V the relationship
with Bruce or Christopher Steele Andrew
Weissman and of course Christopher
Steele doesn't stand by his own dossier
but that didn't stop him from trying to
feed information funnel it through or to
the special counsels office and even
wrote it down by the way today the
president tweeted more text messages
between 4:00
FBI employees struck and page are a
disaster and an embarrassment to the FBI
and DOJ this should never have happened
but we're learning more and more by the
hour how others were leaking like mad in
order to get the president we believed
that to be the CIA which we revealed
last night so the question is Jeff
sessions are you paying attention rod
Rosenstein where are you in this case by
the way Bob Muller are you concerned
steel was funneling information into
your office information he himself
didn't even stand by when he was
involved in an interrogatory in a court
of law and Great Britain he said I don't
know if any of this is true is this
acceptable behavior from the highest
ranking members of our government it is
not Gregg Jarrett Sarah Carter will be
here they'll weigh in on the latest we
also have an update on Supreme Court
nominee judge Brett Kavanaugh his
confirmation vote in the Senate has been
delayed until next week and now after
weeks and weeks of partisan attacks
frankly since the announcement of Judge
Cavanaugh every dirty political tactic
from every Democrat in the Senate well
now at the last minute the last second
these final hour Dianne Feinstein is
throwing a Hail Mary pass a last-ditch
effort to block judge Cavanaugh's
confirmation and Feinstein released
earlier today this cryptic statement
quote I have received information from
an individual concerning the nomination
of Brett Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court
that individual strongly requested
confidentiality declined to come forward
or press the matter further and I have
honored that decision I have however
referred the matter to federal
investigative authorities and according
to reports that information supposedly
surrounds some kind of alleged incident
when Cavanaugh was in high school
40 years ago and two sources are telling
Fox that senator Feinstein has known
about these decades-old allegations
since July she's met with them she's had
chances to confront of about this
publicly and now because nothing is
stuck well now she's beginning to throw
this in at the final hour she questioned
Cavanaugh in private sessions she
questioned him in a public hearing she
said and did nothing you know with his
confirmation looking imminent Feinstein
is trying to pull out all the stops all
the dirty political tactics I warned you
from the beginning this is what they
would do very predictable say
playbook Democrats always find a way to
impugn the character and the standing of
a Republican appointed nominee to the US
Supreme Court it is so common it now has
its own term it's called
Bork II because of this what the
Democrats do to obstruct in the case of
Ronald Reagan's nominee judge Robert
Bork he was never confirmed to the US
Supreme Court in large part because of
the lies the fear mongering from then
mr. character himself senator well drive
the car off the bridge leave the girl on
the cart
Ted Chappaquiddick Kennedy remember this
Robert Bork's America is a land of which
women would be forced into back-alley
abortions blacks would sit at segregated
lunch counters rogue police could break
down citizen's doors and midnight raids
and school children could not be taught
about evolution writers and artists
would be censored at the whim of
government years later Bork II was in
full play during the confirmation
hearings of now Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas 1991 was the year Senate
Democrats they rolled out a former
colleague last-minute made sexual
harassment allegations against him this
case of character assassination was so
vicious so nasty just as Thomas
well infamously now called it a quote
high-tech lynching you may remember this
is a circus it's a national disgrace
and from my standpoint as a black
American as far as I'm concerned it is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks who
in any way deign to think for themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas and it is a message that unless
you count to an old order this is what
will happen to you you will be lynched
destroyed caricatured by a committee of
the u.s. US Senate rather than hung from
a tree now we're watching a last-ditch
effort from Senator Dianne Feinstein she
wants to Bork judge Kavanagh Democrats
made this process so partisan so bitter
so nasty that even Supreme Court justice
liberal hero Ruth Bader Ginsburg has
spoken out take a look
compare the process that you went
through with what's going on today in
that process the way it was was right
the way it is is wrong this becomes a
highly partisan show I wish I could wave
a magic wand and he'll have it go back
to the way
the way it was a highly partisan show
her colleague Justice Clarence Thomas
also criticizing the Democrats for their
political shenanigans take a look
honorable if we could use that word
about more people who are in public life
people who actually ask the questions at
confirmation hearings instead of
Spartacus we use how to get that in
there that in there three hundred other
way Clarence Thomas I've had the honor
of meeting as one of the best laughs
ever the Spartacus line was pretty good
barring any successful balking from the
Democrats Kavanagh should rightfully be
confirmed and he will be this all comes
as the election season is now heating up
we're only 54 days away from the single
most important midterm election of our
lifetime I've long been warning you what
is going to happen if the Democrats take
back the house in November they're going
to rescind the Trump tax cuts they're
going to start impeachment proceedings
they want to keep Obamacare they will
block all originalist constitutionalist
to the court they want activists on the
court they want open borders they're
eliminate ice they want all
investigations into the deep state to
come to an end
Democrats well they will ramp up
investigations and to any and all things
Trump even shiftless Schiff said
yesterday that he'll go full bar on
investigations into money laundering
allegations against Trump I've said it a
million times I'll say it again the
Democrats they want to stop this
administration for being successful in
other words helping you the American
people how do you serve the American
people by involving yourself in
investigations what are the Democrats
offering that will help The Forgotten
men and women in this country they want
to stop the success the economic success
and progress that we have they want to
stop it in its tracks look closely if
you're in one of these states you will
decide the future of the United States
Senate take a very very close look at
that map every one of those states is
important and by the way if you're in
one of these House races take
look we'll scroll it on your screen you
will decide whether or not yet Nancy
Pelosi Adam Schiff Maxine Waters take
control of your future in the house you
get to decide you have the power whether
or not the president
they will impeach him they will raise
your taxes they will they want open
borders they want to keep Obamacare all
of that is true and they're even saying
most of it except the impeachment part
to tell a Maxine is just don't say it
but if the election were held today I
don't think anyone could predict with
any certainty Republicans maintain
control of the House of Representatives
they better come up with a bridge with a
very strong set of principles they all
need to sign it and they all need to
campaign on it it's pretty scary reality
and only you have the power in the end
to stop it from happening
that is Nancy Pelosi and company